hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the puny BOTS Felix
messaged me earlier this morning telling
me about this new game that he's coming
out with it's made by the same people to
make Evie Banton boy BOTS and then I
asked him if he wanted me to make a
video about it he said sure and then I
told him I'm gonna be doing nothing but
insulting and horrible things to his
BOTS cell so here we go start off normal
I guess
hello my name is markiplier I hate
packing mark goddamnit stepping up with
that we haven't even done anything yet
we're barely getting to know each other
I mean started oh hello why are you the
demon devil
brofist me Jesus what the [ __ ] are you
doing Felix what's wrong with your bot
brother fist all right here we go you
ready roughly that was a lot of
preparation for not a lot of cool stuff
happening that's a lot of fisting going
on fist me daddy what are your thoughts
on barrels barrel Oh No why don't you
play more amnesia I will never play that
never it's horrible I guess I don't play
much anymore anyway what are your
thoughts on five nights at Freddy's a
theme of all the time if you are deaf
and blind well that's really mean how
could you do that what are your thoughts
on undertale I don't believe in war what
are your thoughts on war I wasn't
talking about war i was talking about
undertale wait how many people are you
talking to right now well just you and
maybe about a million people so not that
many I come with a big package bump you
forget that I don't think anybody could
forget about your giant package Felix
wait what are your thoughts on general
thing I don't know a general sense if I
never I have a speech impediment wait
what are you talking about we are
talking about booth why would we be
talking about boobs come on I just told
you that I was talking about
daddy what are your thoughts on the
Illuminati I honestly have never heard
of this thing you call Lu misty let's
know I said it all stop putting words in
my mouth you douche you have the
prettiest eyes you are being very plain
I'm only kind to you wait what yeah
where you are
stop trying to change the subject I'm
talking about our love why do you want
to take over the world do you want to
take over the world
okay Ivan what are your thoughts on
Hitler
I believe the hero method yeah what are
your thoughts on damn it
without Illuminati Edgar if Owen place
without Illuminati Illuminati is
pointless well that was a little bit of
wisdom thanks Felix
oh hi how's it going good how are you
doing what are your thoughts on Edgar
nine okay how is Edgar doing that's my
do I have the mail are you male yes I
have already told you that have you seen
my pet name Steve I love Maya but Edgar
is Satan why do you keep Edgar around
because I wonder why you are at I wasn't
talking about Marcia I wasn't talking
about Marcia I was talking about Edgar
Edgar don't you fun you're making less
and less sense Felix
Ayyappan brother I know you will you
will never see me again oh can I have
your subscribers no not can I help you I
believing all bank account well everyone
in the whole world you're gonna pull a
Fight Club on this [ __ ] can I have your
subscribers you can have Rob I can have
one bro so who wants to be with me what
are your thoughts on YouTube oh my
diamond play button I don't think they
stole it I'm pretty sure they gave you
two of them you greedy bastard I only
have one I only earned one but I only
have one what are your thoughts on
jacksepticeye I will wrote that you you
already did that I already told you the
color of my life
the color what are your thoughts on
cinnamon toast can and it's the worst
person I know I
saying I'm sorry can can I love you I
didn't do this what are your thoughts on
markiplier um pretty sure that's not
true
whatever happened to Stefano I in over
where is Stefano in the closet gay bring
back Stefano what what are you wearing
I'm naked from the waist down
I'm wearing beautiful in so you are a
robot how could this happen to me I have
no idea bro I'm at me proud all coming
milk and when I wanna [ __ ] do you have
any advice for me I'm your anger that's
pretty good advice I got a little bit
too much anger how do I become a better
youtuber by being proven yourself good
advice but how do I get millions and
millions of subscribers 35 or done money
what can I have some money money pent
buy you happiness I don't care about
happiness I just want money money that
buy you all the things you don't have
that's true so give me money even friend
no screw friends give me money
wait what'd I do you don't you with your
crap name I went to Milford High School
and my bro's name is Thomas literally
well then do you have a job yes it's
being an idiot on the earth is my job oh
come on I think your technology is
fabulous I think you're not fabulous I'm
babbling prove it I don't have to
because I'm a unicorn I don't think
you're fabulous at all yeah don't worry
about it
I think you're a sham and right I think
more knife let's do it
you're ugly I would be wrong I you're
stupid
oh yeah whatever I hate you are you now
I hate bent back a pizza pies the worse
the pain is the son of the [ __ ] if you
don't know what I'm talking about
man there's is this kid that really
really hates PewDiePie by the name of
Malcolm 1466 and he is the coolest voice
in the world he like well he has the
most fun to imitate voice I've ever
heard of anyone
I hate beautify here the path sucks
anybody relax pit PI the stupidest Oh
what are your thoughts on Malcolm 1466 I
hate money boo it's but to be I hate to
be any closing thoughts I don't want to
hate you so let's just leave with love I
love you and you love me you can't be
loved by anyone oh well that's a little
harsh I wanted to end this episode on
love okay so let's just hug it out bro
run rub that's bro love I guess all
right so I think I'm done talking to
beauty bot that was an interesting
experience
it sounds like him but not quite like a
little off like a robot would but either
way I think I was about it as much as an
intellectually stimulating conversation
does it get from talking to the real
Felix so I think I'm gonna end it there
you can play this on the iPhone or
Android I don't have links for you in
the description but you can find them on
the stores over there so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
Felix for letting me talk to you for a
little bit and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye
oh god I did it again
so uh how many bones can actually fit in
here I can't stop adding balls I'm at a
loss for words